la rusia vladimir putin ha sido durante
mucho tiempo admirada e incluso
cortejada por bnp en una posición muy
criticada desde la invasión rusa de
ucrania por lo que la cantidad de
agrupación nacional ha querido dejar
clara su visión se declara partidaria de
reforzar los vínculos entre la otan y
moscú ayer es tan pronto como la guerra
entre rusia y ucrania haya terminado y
tengamos un tratado de paz propondré un
acercamiento estratégico entre la otan y
rusia ratificó luto en el darius y otra
medida defendida por más del epp en la
retirada de francia del mando militar
integrado de la otan para recuperar más
soberanía asegura la candidata en
segundo lugar quiere poner fin a la
cooperación industrial con alemania una
posición justificada por los intereses
divergentes entre ambos países aunque la
candidata ya no defiende el president y
el abandono del euro sigue siendo
crítica con las limitaciones impuestas
por la legislación europea
una historia totalmente diferente es la
de su rival emanuel mccoy que es
abiertamente pro europeo el presidente
saliente aboga por una unión europea
fuerte y energéticamente independiente y
la lucha que estamos librando no es sólo
una lucha por franja es una lucha por
europa porque el proyecto de
ultraderecha que tenemos delante va en
contra del proyecto que yo defiendo en
nombre de muchos de los que están aquí
es un proyecto oculto ahora es más
ambiguo pero es un proyecto para salir
de europa
después de catalogar como muerte a la
otan en 2019 marco instó a la alianza a
unificarse justificando su decisión por
la guerra que está a las puertas de la
unión europea también pidió que se
aplicaran fuertes sanciones contra moscú
el actual presidente es partidario de la
estabilidad política en tiempos de
crisis una estabilidad que pretende
encarnar